Hello, Sir Elton John.
This is your personalized weather forecast from the new weather.com.
It's another lovely day in London.
We've got overcast conditions.
16 degrees Celsius ought to top us out.
UV index right there around a moderate three.
So, if you're out and about,...
...it wouldn't hurt to wear a pair of those really sweet, periwinkle, star-shaped, glitter-covered sunglasses...
...that we've all seen you in and really what you're known for, quite frankly.
Overnight lows will drop right around eight degrees so it shouldn't be all that bad.
Go outside with a light jacket like this, nice and tight.
Don't forget to check back on the new weather.com to see what your weekend has in store.
Enjoy your day in cloudy London.